podría sentar un precedente legal el
lunes un juez de una corte de quiebras
sentenció a cadena perpetua a un soldado
ruso acusado de cometer crímenes de
guerra a finales de febrero badín si si
marín de 21 años disparó contra un
hombre que iba en bicicleta en la
localidad de sapac ipca en el noreste de
ucrania ha
sido el 17 de octubre del 2000 es
declarado culpable de haber cometido
ofensa criminal de acuerdo el artículo
438 del código penal ucraniano queda
condenado a cadena perpetua el soldado
no mostró ningún tipo de emoción al
escuchar el veredicto su abogado había
intentado buscar una absolución
argumentando que su cliente tan solo
ejecutó una orden directa que
anteriormente había desobedecido hace
unos días aseguró a la corte que no
tenía intenciones de matar
[Música]
me arrepiento sinceramente estaba
nervioso porque en el momento en el que
ocurrió había enfrentamientos yo no
quería matar a la víctima pero así es
como ocurrió y no lo niego
su caso no será el último ucrania acusa
a rusia de atrocidades generalizadas y
brutalidad contra la población civil las
autoridades han identificado más de
10.000 posibles crímenes de guerra
cometidos por rusia el kremlin niega que
sus tropas hayan matado a civiles